I always forget how big you are because
so many people in show business are tall
I mean are not tall and you are six four
six six six six is a cube or yeah you're
six six seventeen since you were 17 you
see you grew very quickly and and here's
the thing I have found I'm six four and
people they've learned since then but
because I was told they assumed that I
was a great athlete yes do you get that
it's such a curse strangers will ask me
do you play basketball and think on it I
do and I'm outstanding but I always
think what if I didn't yeah then it's
the equivalent of saying hey what was
the biggest disappointment for your
father what continues to be a source in
March yeah yeah yeah just you feel like
you let them down well I did because I'm
tall and I'm you are probably a decent
athlete I I just didn't have much
interest wasn't very good at it and so
people would pick me right and they'd be
like we got him yay and then with yes
within seconds it was like what have we
done
do you play we're both from
Massachusetts you play hockey
well I tried I wanted to what I really
wanted to do was skate the the thing I
don't know if you find this people also
assume that you're aggressive when
you're big and that you're tough and you
know back people up in in a hockey fight
yeah and I wanted no part of that but in
Massachusetts in the 70s yes figure
skating just wasn't an option you the
ridicule I know
I am so right there with you know in the
70s in Boston because the Bruins by your
you everyone had to play hockey
yes and you would be ridiculed for just
wanting to skate there had to be some
potential for a broken nose or or a jaw
or something like that and hold a stick
yeah yeah and I always used to say
figure skating is no less brutal than
hockey it's just more an emotional thing
where if you fall they make you finish
your routine in the industry you have to
get up again going lowest part in your
life keep dancing sweetie yeah yeah try
another lutz
[Laughter]